all right so this is a real thought on
The Last Airbender I don't wanna hurt we
must take on the shaman on um we're real
foots I think match the review pretty
well what a minor that mine aren't quite
as like angry I think because I knew
going in it was gonna be bad
unlike the crowd going in who thought
like you know this is not quite at the
point where Shyamalan was the kiss of
death
it's his feels were getting bad but it's
like avatar was the kissing you know
then it really kind of what I was the
final straw yeah cuz now not only has he
made something bad but it destroyed
something that made you know some of the
people you know that it destroyed the
possibility for an even bigger franchise
you know like a movie franchise um but
the kind gets to the other thing about
the film - may why did anger me as much
it's still terrible but ah there's no
emotions to have cuz that bland well no
it's just there's it's a dumb idea to
make a film based on the first season of
something I mean fuckin anything really
ah because you're not gonna do anything
you're gonna piss off people you had to
shove in so much stuff would have had to
have done six movies total and do
probably two films becae you may have
been able to condense season two down to
one movie I mean there there's
definitely like filler happening on how
much you just want to suck out of the
earth Kingdom stuff yeah not now though
now don't get me wrong that's not the
only thing wrong with the film but I
would kind of argue that is like just
from the initial idea even if Shyamalan
didn't suck you're right it would have
been almost doomed from the start
because you're trying to do that I don't
know how the hell I would have had to
have literally the yeah you would have
had to have the world's best
screenwriter I mean somebody's so
brilliant that they're like I know
exactly what to keep what to cut and how
to make this work how to make people
happy you mean what if we had to have
Peter Jackson circa Fellowship of the
Ring like yeah that Peter Jed not Hobbit
people yeah but that Peter Jackson from
Fellowship of the Ring where it's like
he knew just enough and then you could
have done like an extended edition on
DVD like and I think that's almost what
they were looking at they were trying to
almost think like kami
like a Lord of the Rings thing with this
series like could be
although cuz it had a co2 it like
fantasy world kind of yeah this is a
valuable time they started to come out
right the Lord of Rings movies or what
would have been after this we would have
been maybe this is not that old three
three four years after Return of the
King it says okay so maybe like a secure
one yeah um I love you this week we
still would have been I think in Harry
Potter mode mm-hmm which itself was also
kind of like war to the ring they're
like you know all that whole fantasy
thing that's I feel like that's slowly
dying out it's now all Hunger Games and
Twilight related but um but yeah so I
mean this the the things wrong with it
are pretty obvious uh everything yeah I
mean it is trying to think of one thing
it did well um I kayak I do kind of like
the addition one a few additions of of
him not bowing back and that's sort of
the final thing at the end that he
finally can do you know it's him
accepting the role as the avatar I
thought that was a decent up visual to
like show okay he's accepting this and
it's not talking cuz there's enough are
you talking about the very last where
he's all like sad looking and well I
mean not that it was necessarily done
well but I like the idea that this is
her house mass at Central gods because
Aang slowly accepts responsibility and
like has is it but man there was like no
sense of fun that look at his face it's
like this I was like I think he just
watched his like puppy gets shot like
and I was like yeah I certainly want to
see the sequel with you know oh that was
not fun at all that poor girl who was
playing as Ulla you know she just just
like hide watching the show I'm gonna be
like the main villain such a juicy role
they're like nothing happens but that
was probably the best thing that could
have happened to you on it
yeah doesn't anyone that falls under
shall Millan's direction is just like
you know your doll and he really is like
now that Lukas is out of the game he
really is our modern-day like George
Lucas still I was gonna say kind of like
the new I don't want say new what chance
keep Rio which ask you for a second
ideas um but it is kind of the same
thing where it's just like it's it's not
only being really dull but it's really
thinking you're saying very important
major stuff that nobody's ever thought
of and that kind of stuff drives me nuts
when you know even okay I know you just
get matrix II acting sucks I'm sorry if
I put the matrix up against a last year
but no no no ma'am it and I'll talk
about you get her ascending lion enemies
from what I've heard like it's so goofy
kind of bad yeah like it's so crazy no
that's why I can't quite compare it to
that because we still have interesting
ideas or shamba one really has no again
is I've just never seen a director like
it's not just the fact that the acting
is bad because that is always Lucas's
problem the acting is just bad its hokey
he can't direct any actor out of a paper
bag unless they're British in which case
I just ya know it seemed to know it's a
good hat yes apparently Brits seem to
know naturally how to just act without
direction but um it's not just the fact
that it's bad it's that it's so soulless
there is no feeling no emotion I know
people just like oval Anakin like he
says it yeah but there's a there's even
more emotion in like a nigga like it's
over the top like it's only one you love
it back at least its whiny like there's
magic at least it's mighty at least ya
be mommy from a very low place if you
say at least it's ym you
why me like what I remember watching
last urban I'm like no one has human
emotions in a Shyamalan film
they all tie in and that is a problem
with the Wachowski z' but the Wachowski
somehow just do it better not great you
know how you were talking about is there
anything that's actually good and stuff
i forgot that the kid that played Zuko
and he was he was good but that's the
Slumdog Millionaire came like you yes he
did yeah and that and I damn well better
be he's the only one that came out of it
and I wrote world Kazuko and IRA were
okay oh so basically the two characters
that you would have to work extra hard
to destroy are okay Brett pretty much
like I mean those two character that I
mean if you're writing should be facing
those characters right themselves like
they looked oh they look totally
different you know kind of in many
respects even act totally different uh
but they stalk about us okay you felt a
connection between knowing how much that
Shyamalan what do we call it Shama
Liza's it yeah you've been Shama lized
knowing how much he does that can you
imagine how great our oath and cyka
would have been it had felt someone else
directed it yeah because I mean that
shows you that they are cut above the
rest of the normal actors who probably
would have just given normal
performances yeah I would have been
amazing you know there was a just for
shits and giggles we took a look at the
deleted scenes after watching the movie
and there is a scene that it was a
stupid scene but at least it was trying
to get in some comedy where he goes to
this fortune-teller
uh and you know the fortune-teller is
obviously faking and then at some point
it gets really possessed or something
like that and there's one scene where
that kid you know she's faking being a
fortune-teller like she's being
possessed and the one scene where Aang
just kind of goes like that I was like
you got it that was it was egg that's
their yeah I would do um you know but
but it almost looked like the little
animation yeah like I wanted to see like
a little squiggle right yeah no like
that actually legitimately felt like uh
felt like egg um but yeah I can't think
of life any of the other characters they
don't like to let you the two leads I
feel bad because if you star in a
Shyamalan movie
you're either signing Yorker
your way or basically opening yourself
to being called terrible particularly if
you're new and it's hard to tell if it's
on them or Shama because he sucks the
life out of good actors so I can't
well Wahlberg he's an actor and you see
him in the half thing like what the hell
did he do but those two the uh Katara
and um why am i blinking Sokka Sokka
yeah Katara and Sokka I'm sorry yeah kit
the two of them are just so bad that I
feel bad it's embarrassing it's like
watching somebody fail onstage like
you're watching like a school play and
you've got that kid that's terrible and
you just you just feel bad for them and
they're hoping nobody records it but now
this is forever you know on DVD like and
I can't like 100% tell if they're just
truly that awful um they're just bad
actors or if just without any sort of
direction from Shyamalan or bad
direction you know they were just made
to be that bad yeah I mean we've seen
good actors rotated vote from Shyamalan
and Luke it's the stuff that gonna end
up it done fines but it is it is Anakin
it is Hayden Christensen bed it is an
epic bad like I remember watching it and
just like her reading her lines and but
it's hard to make those lines sound
natural
no I'm this way too that's true so it's
like I don't know like if they're
actually decent actors then I I'm so
sorry like I'm sorry you had the
misfortune of getting stuck in this film
well they're um which brings up a good
point you know there was all to talk
about you know sort of whitewashing and
now I got a couple of white actors to
play I will say this that may have been
the greatest thing to ever happen to
Asian actors ever because any Asian
actors that ended up in that film and in
the role of Qatar that you have we've
never seen them again why it would
destroyed their career so thank you
Shyamalan for saving you know summation
actors grief well and I guess we should
probably bring up to that there was talk
about why the movie was not good why at
least the choices of the race was made
um from what we from what we've heard
apparently like the girl playing Katara
like what was kind of shoehorn in
because she was like the daughter of
like uh some sort of powerful person
Hollywood but she's okay
you could have gone a studio executive
or producers like some sort of powerful
person well I don't know I mean I am
here I generally cannot remember but you
know I I heard there were somebody you
know or some sort of a member can
shoehorn her in and said she's gonna be
in this movie uh well she needs a
brother she's white brothers got a be
way okay so so they're white means
grandma has to be white yeah so but and
then they sort of said well but we can't
just make them all kind of why we have
to diversify it a bit so let's just make
you know the Fire Nation to die skin
which is like oops that didn't exactly
help things um but then at least
explains a little bit to be fair though
a lot of them are Indian actors so what
are you gonna be like Shyamalan hates
himself
yeah well that was kind of well no that
was the one big concerns like you know
did Shyamalan even sell out his own race
or whatever but I don't know I was never
quite ready to believe that um I didn't
find it strangely enough I didn't find
the casting so much racist like because
most of the Fire Nation are the
quote-unquote bad guys but really by the
end of the series it's just you know the
Fire Lord
I mean everybody else is simply
following orders and the to sympathetic
character I mean there's some baddies
guy yeah I mean it's still yes oh shoot
oh and Zaire really juicy roles like it
I almost argue the opposite that like I
think Shamu may have realized that the
juiciest roles in those are the villains
you know maybe he was trying to cut the
Indian actors a favor by getting you
know I don't know um so yeah I mean III
didn't me personally I didn't
immediately think like races or whatever
um I did think horrible miss casting
because I'll tell you why if you wanted
to put white actors and that's why could
have made the earth Kingdom white could
the Fire Nation the airbenders you know
there's something about in you and
with culture like Eskimos sort of
culture and I might look right
what's that cuz the rest of them were
kind of yeah and I'm not talking about
it like with Scandinavians all right
that's fine but they're living at the
polls the statistics and they literally
have like the Eskimo yeah showing
everything and I guess I got no fantasy
whatever but I'm like okay what is this
because everyone else look genuine stuff
I mean they look like it's racist it
could have been way more raise it like
it that that's a thing I could have been
North I found it more I guess he was my
thing I found it more incompetence than
racism like it's almost like they were
so innocent to net they didn't think
anybody would be like no really like
you're races radula
that doesn't good way of putting it I
think it's a it's more ignorance and
incompetence to me than like yeah
Shyamalan is seriously being like no as
an Indian actor I'm gonna be totally
racist against my own kind and then cast
the Inuits his white people III don't
see a conspiracy
he's many things he's probably not that
um so yeah I think even what else a lot
of people really hated the effects I
don't think they're good I didn't quite
think they were the worst
like I thought Appa looked okay any
looks like the car destruction is
something that a middle-of-the-road
Nickelodeon movie would throw out yeah I
kind of which is the whole movie like I
think it should have been like Lord of
the Rings or something really high class
and instead we got like you know one of
those middle-of-the-road fantasy like
Harry Potter knock-offs instead yeah so
I mean it's like they weren't the worst
we've seen far worse a fact um you know
don't we do is watch bad movies yeah
they're not but they're very good um but
the only other thing I'll say is that I
think probably if I had to guess like
the biggest sort of fault of Shyamalan
is that I think I think a lot of
directors used to fall in this trap bar
I don't see it as much but they focus
much more on making their directing
unique rather than their fill
unique they want to make sure that
you're noticing that they're doing
something different or that they have a
style look at my style and I get that I
get why a lot of directors do that
because there are so many and you want
to stand out and be unique and have your
vision a lot of people want be the next
Kubrick or or Burton they all have their
distinct styles uh but yeah I think now
there was sort of a point for a while
especially like in the late 90s and
early 2000s were just everyone was
trying to have the artistic vision on
screen and it was just all gelling
together I'm looking ridiculous one
channel ends case particularly with
avatar the biggest you know what the
biggest sin for me is it's not sucking
the life out of it it's not sucking the
we all know these as Shyamalan tropes it
was the lack of color in a show that was
so I mean for what Nickelodeon they had
to work with we can look at Korra and be
like oh the animation is really you know
they stepped it up a number notches
visit but for what they had to work with
like the original avatar on Nickelodeon
stunningly gorgeous Oh a beautiful color
show like the colors on that show were
amazing sound looks good it is it's not
budget to score now but it's like it's
you yeah it holds up beautifully and to
just see this bland gray ugly film that
is the biggest sin because I was like
you couldn't even nail the look of it
right doesn't even look like if you had
told me it was avatar last airbender I
would have been able to guess it on my
own watch it like a good 20 minutes of
it I would have had to pick up on plot
points I've been like really that's went
from this to this like fail yeah I think
Appa looked okay and I think the sort of
the ice uh whatever sphere circle
whatever that he was trapped in like
that looked okay and I was like yeah
like that kind of existed in real life
as well would look like uh but yeah
everything else you're right is just so
bland and ugly and not pleasant to look
at where the show was such the opposite
and again maybe that's the idea of like
well we're it get dark and gritty
because everything you know if you want
be serious you have to be dark and
gritty which I'm so glad that's dying
out you know and I love dark things I
I mean you look at my favorite movies I
love dark things uh but just this idea
that that's uh making adult I do is just
a tool making something dark and gritty
doesn't make it better yeah I mean it's
like you say it's a tool you use to help
something but it's not you know that's
not it's not a tool that's going to help
avatar avatar did not look dark and
gritty and guess what it we're just fine
yeah um doesn't need to look like the
fucking crow
so yeah Jonathan did not too much else I
think the only thing that comes to mind
is uh it was fascinating to see a film
that had a fan base cuz you know most
people uh when you have somebody has a
fan base like whatever the Phantom
Menace when it came out like Oh a lot of
people do like if a lot of people were
in that denial because they wanted to
love it so much there is no denial over
this ya know this was that there's a
world video out there is where trail no
no there was a wonderful video out there
somewhere I forget who did it but it was
some sort of like entertainment group
that got you know opening night
reactions from fans and usually people
kind of half-and-half or mostly cowboy
again so don't know and every person
they interview for Last Airbender they
hated it talked about it like they were
all hating it and finally the guy just
you know near the end yet there's a
whole bunch of fans lined up like
dressed up like the characters the stuff
he finally just turns in the middle of
this interview with one of the fancy
justice did anybody like this film and
everyone just in this big war went oh it
was amazing the amount of hatred that
people have for it you know that was not
just you know a fan boys and girls I
mean this was like really you know like
this was a boring movie there is easily
recognized there is one difference I
mean this this was a property that was
already there that the whole story was
told and your readapting it for a movie
at least with Phantom Menace they were
getting a new story so I think there was
just as much confusion uh-huh more than
cuz nobody knew what this story was
gonna be now if you had tried to remake
Star Wars and like insert things like
Jar Jar Binks into it and change the
language of the feeling like yeah I
think
would have been way more universally
hated um although I guess he kind of did
that the special edition but not quite
to the Phantom Menace levels um so oh
you know the era the the redoing of the
era with those symbols I thought that
was a good addition how do you make that
arrow not look ridiculous I thought that
was a good way around it I thought that
that was actually pretty close some
painful tattooing doing that Mouse all
right oh hey kid
come over here this is really going to
hurt so um yeah it's still bad I like I
said I think because I knew going in it
was going to be bad I wasn't as angry
and honestly last airbender the the
avatar lessor butter was so good it's
like not even that movie can knock me
off that just the good feeling that
gives me so I think it's just a
testament to how good a show is they
even a film that almost you Jimmy Caan
movie but you'll never take a TV show
yeah I mean it's just a sense it's like
just even a movie that bad and saying no
these are your characters it's like no
no I these characters are so real I know
who they really are these aren't the
characters and nice try but no I still
got my characters on DVD and I'll watch
them whenever I want and they're
phenomenal so fuck you mr. Shah momma we
got our own show so that's about it guys
if there's any other movies you want to
see us talk honestly about that we've
reviewed leave them in the comments
below and we'll try our best to get to
them
take care